- Well hey, let's bring
in the other judges
I think that-
- No.
Let's just keep it you and I.
I'm happy.
(Kelly laughs)
- We have to bring them
in, they've been waiting.
- I'm not ready.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
- Oh my God.
- I need the blue shirt
- (groans) I didn't didn't wanna see that.
- (mumbles) Howie, no.
- Oh, this is like a horror movie.
(Terry laughs)
- I love you so much right now.
Oh my god.
- What are you doing?
- You wanna know honestly
what I doing, Simon?
- I think, I have a feeling
and I don't wanna see it.
(Kelly laughs)
- You inspired me, Simon,
that you were able to-
- What?
- Well, here's what it is.
- Tell me.
- Terry Crews is the
consummate host, good friend
and everything, what is he known for,
besides hosting our show?
- Having huge pecks.
(Kelly laughs)
- And being able to control them right?
(Terry laughs loudly)
And you can do it now too, right?
- I can do it right now, as well, yeah.
- Let see.
- Hang on, I don't know if this shows.
- Okay, hang on a second.
- There you go.
There it is.
- Fresh.
- Yes.
- I mean it's not as good as you, Terry
but I'm getting there.
- No, it's amazing.
- Guys, I've been practicing at home.
I'm not there yet but-
(Terry laughs loudly)
- Oh my god.
- What?
- Kelly, when you edit the show
you can edit out the strings
and everything, so I
look more talented, no?
- This is (mumbles)
- You know what, Howie?
You know what you look like?
You know when you get
one of these really bad
auditions on the show
and all you're thinking
is how quickly can I
get you off the stage?
(Kelly laughs)
- We're in that kinda place right now.
- Are you giving me the red buzzer?
(Kelly muffled)
- Yes, millions of them.